. Okay, let's go to the phones at six one
seven eight three zero 47 50.
See what's on people's minds.
Let's go first to our caller from the nine
one seven areaCode, who we last spoke to in.
Well, it's been a year, actually, nine one
seven.
What's going on?
Hi, David.
Hi.
I'm calling about the genocide that's going
on in singeing China against the Turkic peoples,
including the wiggers.
Yes, there's a there's a bill that's been
like in committee since March called, I think,
the Wigger Forced Labor Prevention Act, which
I believe which would which would cause corporations
that have factories in Shenzhen to prove that
their supply chains don't include slave labor
from wiggers rather than in other words, they
would put the burden on them.
And I just sort of wanted to make kind of
a shout out for that legislation.
There's been very little pressure that I've
seen put on people to to make progress on
that.
And I just think that's really crucial because
right now, sort of like we are all probably
walking around in clothing, in face masks,
I mean, all kinds of things that are made
by these, you know, a million
people detained.
And that's sort of like a very pressing human
rights issue.
Yeah, I think that one of the things that
is an interesting aspect of this that maybe
isn't being discussed is when we talk about
American relations with China, one of the
realities we have to face is that the worse
our relationship is with China, the less leverage
we have to get them to change their behavior
or to make demands or whatever.
And so, you know, a lot of the discussion
about Trump and China is about where the tariffs
are good or bad idea or what is the relationship
between China and Russia that builds when
the U.S. is increasingly on the outs in that
group of three countries, beneficial or not?
But there's this other reality that if Trump
cared to do something about what's going on
there, we have a lot less leverage when our
relationship is bad and and when we cut ties.
And
that's sort of like an ancillary intangible
that we have to understand is affected by
the relationship the Oval Office has with
China.
Can I sort of put another way?
Put another way of looking at that?
Yeah.
Not an argument.
This is sort of a reframing is like one of
the things I think about is when we look back,
you know, 10 years from now, we're saying
in the Trump era, the U.S. had a very bad
relationship with China.
And people are going to ask, well, oh, that
makes sense, because China was a totalitarian
state that was putting a million people in
concentration camps that doing medical experimentation
and testing, that he thought people obviously
would have a bad relationship with China.
And the answer is, well, no, actually, that
really wasn't the issue at all.
Actually, we just had a problem with, you
know, they were selling soybeans kind of cheap.
And I don't want to undercut portions of that.
Right.
Yeah.
But now now, of course, it's all it's more
than enough that they are more than happy
to like it the way it was in the 50s.
Yes.
And of course, it's more complicated than
just even even the soybean explanation.
But you're right that when we look back at
it, it may be misremembered.
But listen, this is one of the really the
the additional reasons why having actual diplomats
or people who defer to diplomats still matters
in 2020.
And having people who prioritize human rights,
I mean, in care.
I mean, I would I would point just in one
second that the Biden campaign put out a very
good statement the other day.
There is the Trump administration is apparently
considering labeling this a genocide, which
I think would be an enormous step.
Hopefully they do that.
The Biden campaign put out a good statement
saying, I believe, saying we will do that
if we come into office.
But I think that's something that we should
be putting a lot of pressure on institutions
to do right now is to really make some kind
of impact on that issue.
All right.
Not a not an unreasonable idea.
I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you, David.
All right, take care.